Mainstream TV viewers often overlook
horror, but American Horror Story
managed to seduce an audience all its own.
Before American Horror Story debuted in 2011,
co-creator Ryan Murphy was best known as
one of the minds behind Glee, a show so
happy and positive that it was literally about
a bunch of high school kids gaining self esteem
by singing and dancing to familiar pop songs.
Murphy then went directly from his high school
musical to a house full of ghosts, violence, and
a Rubber Man. What happened? Who hurt you, Ryan?
In an interview with Elle, Murphy admitted:
"I was like, 'I can't write any more nice
speeches for these Glee kids about
love and tolerance and togetherness.'"
To that end, he wrote a show about horror and
depravity instead. American Horror Story also
allowed Murphy to right a Glee wrong. He'd
wanted Sarah Paulson to play Emma Pillsbury,
the high school guidance counselor eventually
portrayed by Jayma Mays. Paulson was unable
because she was starring in a Broadway play
at the time. Murphy finally found a place for
Paulson as medium Billie Dean Howard, the first
of many memorable AHS roles she would step into.
"So much pain here. So much longing and regret."
While occasionally campy and darkly funny,
most every season of American Horror
Story gets pretty bleak pretty quickly.
"I mean, just because you've got 30
bodies buried in your crawl space,
don't mean you can't have a really terrific
rec room and be a respectable businessman."
Playing murderers — and their victims — can
really get under the skin of the actors,
so a few have tried to relieve
the tension when possible.
Zachary Quinto took on a major role in Asylum
as Oliver Thredson. Another role he accepted:
on-set music therapist, playing his banjo
on set to lighten the mood. Lily Rabe
plays guitar in real life, and she'd play to
provide "musical breaks" on tough days too.
"Yeah. Musical breaks. It was good. Zach is better
at the banjo than I am at the guitar, for sure."
Jessica Lange, the grande dame of American
Horror Story, convinced Ryan Murphy to put
one of these melodic palette cleansers
into the show itself. After a flashback
revealed that her Asylum character
had once been a singer in a band,
Lange suggested a full-on fantasy musical sequence
in the middle of a psychiatric institution — set
to the classic '60s novelty song "The Name
Game" — if only because, as she told Vulture:
"Everything we do is so grim."
Before it was canceled in 2017,
Scream Queens — Ryan Murphy's other
other show — was the place where the
blood and gore of American Horror Story
met the comedy of Glee. For instance,
its first season asked the burning question: How
might a cast made up of self-absorbed sorority
girls and dumb frat guys deal with a costumed
serial killer roaming their college campus?
"Good evening, idiot hookers. I'm very happy to
welcome you to hell week here at Kappa House."
It was also laced with references to classic
slasher movies, tongue-in-cheek horror movie
tropes, and it even starred Halloween's
Jamie Lee Curtis in a major role.
While that may all sound pretty standard for
the guy who conjured up the Dead Breakfast Club,
Scream Queens nearly had even more in common
with American Horror Story. Just how much,
you ask? Well, it was almost a spin-off of Coven,
the AHS season set at a school
for young witches in New Orleans.
"Surprise, bitch. I bet you
thought you'd seen the last of me."
However, Murphy changed his mind after
a lunch with Fox executives, explaining:
"We were talking about things that
we loved that were not on the air,
things that we loved growing up,
movies that we loved watching."
Once the subject of slasher movies came up,
Scream Queens' own unique identity began to
take shape — and while its ride was a short
one, it sure was a blast while it lasted.
"I'm going to kill you now."
"Wait. Whaaaat???"
In the months before
the sixth season of American
Horror Story premiered in 2016,
FX released more than 20 teasers, each
suggesting a totally different theme.
At a Television Critics Association
event, FX CEO John Landgraf explained
that only one of them accurately represented
the season — while the rest were "misdirects."
Though wildly different, the trailers did share
a few things in common: all of them were creepy,
weird, and pretty damn unsettling, perhaps
none more so than one that showed a woman
using some hedge clippers to snip wind
chimes made from human teeth. Turns out
that was the real trailer, as that imagery
figures into American Horror Story: Roanoke.
In a way, though, all of the fake
trailers were "real." That season
of the show explored the notions of "real"
and "fake," as the plot centered in part on
a couple who lived in a haunted house near
the lost colony of Roanoke, and a TV show's
re-creations of the events they endured at
the hands of the ghostly Roanoke colonists.
In American Horror Story: Hotel, Evan Peters
portrayed Mr. March, who turned out to be
arguably the most super evil character in the
show's long list of super evil characters.
"I look around, and I see the
definition of American success."
Why? Well, because he trapped, tortured,
and killed people in the Hotel Cortez
— duh. It's quite upsetting then that,
according to Ryan Murphy in Entertainment
Weekly, Mr. March is based on a real person.
That individual is H.H. Holmes, who,
during the Chicago World's Fair in 1893,
opened and ran a "hotel of horrors." Visitors
to the great exposition who tragically chose
to stay at Holmes' hotel would find
their rooms soundproof and windowless,
all the better for Holmes to take
them out via gassing or other means.
Secret passageways allowed him to remove
bodies to the basement without detection,
where he'd destroy the evidence in a furnace. He
was caught in 1894, and executed two years later.
In addition to legendary Oscar winners
like Jessica Lange and Kathy Bates,
American Horror Story has made stars out of
up-and-comers like Emma Roberts and Evan Peters,
and proved to the world long before A Star
is Born that Lady Gaga could act. It's hard
to believe that some performers couldn't or
didn't want to be involved with the top-rated
show. Chris Zylka booked a two-episode stint on
Asylum as a deaf man, but a few months later,
he exited because he didn't want to have to
shave his head, a requirement of the role.
Ryan Murphy has also dutifully
pursued a few dream cast members,
albeit unsuccessfully. Among the targets he has
revealed: Michelle Pfeiffer, Michael Chiklis,
and Reese Witherspoon. Talking about the
latter to Entertainment Weekly, Murphy said -
"I wanted her to play something really twisted
and f***ed up. But she's always booked."
Neil Patrick Harris and his husband, David Burtka,
appeared in Freak Show, although Murphy earlier
pursued the couple for Murder House — he wanted
them to portray the bickering pair ultimately
played by Zachary Quinto and Teddy Sears. Harris
explained to Rolling Stone why they skipped out on
the part, referring to the couple's roles
in A Very Harold & Kumar 3D Christmas -
"We had just played ourselves as a
couple not getting along. I thought,
'It just seems weird to do that
twice, as individual actors to
play a couple that hate each other twice.
So I said 'no,' that we shouldn't do it."
The eighth season of American Horror Story,
dubbed Apocalypse, tied together characters
from multiple seasons in the ultimate
crossover event to face the ultimate evil:
Michael Langdon, the offspring of Satan – the
antichrist. In the sixth episode of the story,
"Return to Murder House," viewers learn that
Michael realizes his evil abilities in full after
a visit from Anton LaVey and his top lieutenants,
who ritually and brutally sacrifice a woman,
remove her beating heart, and give it over to
the young embodiment of true evil to feast upon.
It was a deeply upsetting scene for many viewers,
but in a different way for the real-life Church
of Satan. Anton LaVey was a real person, who
really did found the Church of Satan and wrote
several books espousing the beliefs of the
10,000-strong organization. Present-day COS
leaders objected to the portrayal of the church
on American Horror Story, tweeting about their
disapproval in October 2018 and pointing
out the inaccuracies in the adaptation.
When Ryan Murphy talked to The Hollywood
Reporter regarding Sarah Paulson's
portrayal of Bette and Dot Tattler during
the fourth season of American Horror Story,
he couldn't hold back his
overwhelming praise, saying -
"It's absolutely the most challenging
thing I've ever seen any actor do ever."
"It was really terrifying as you might
imagine - I didn't know how in the
world we were going to do it and it's a
really scary thing to act by yourself."
The dual role found Paulson playing conjoined
twins with two heads and one body, living in a
traveling sideshow on American Horror Story: Freak
Show. It was also one of the most challenging
things the show's special effects artists ever
had to attempt. It required a lot of old-fashioned
trickery, labor, and digital manipulation for
Paulson to convincingly play both characters.
First, the effects team took
a mold of Paulson's own head
and used it to build two sophisticated
prosthetic heads, as Murphy explained -
"So when Sarah is doing her coverage where
she's Dot, she has on a fake head to her left,
which is Bette, and it moves. She
literally has to do scenes with herself."
Those scenes took as long as 15 hours to shoot,
because everything with the Tattlers had to be
filmed for close-up, in medium shots, for
effects, and from various angles...twice.
American Horror Story: Freak Show takes place in
Florida among the denizens of one of few remaining
"Cabinet of Curiosities" shows in 1952. A
highlight of the season is the recurring
motif of anachronistic music from musicians like
Nirvana and David Bowie, meaning characters set
in the show's world of the early '50s sing
very famous songs recorded decades later.
Ryan Murphy explained that the songs
were carefully selected for Freak Show,
and for good reason, as he explained -
"We decided we only were going
to highlight musical artists who
at some point in their career had
identified themselves as feeling
like freaks or misfits or outcasts,
which our people are going through."
American Horror Story: Hotel took inspiration
in part from the ghastly horrors committed by
H.H. Holmes, and seemingly from something more
modern and ambiguous as well. The Hotel Cortez
is loosely based on the Cecil Hotel, a structure
in the "skid row" area of downtown Los Angeles
that's hosted countless tourists and transients
as well as murderers and mysteries. Austrian
serial killer Jack Unterweger resided at the
hotel for a while, as did Richard Ramirez,
the murderer known as the Night Stalker. He's
even a character in American Horror Story: Hotel.
The one incident that really moved the needle
for American Horror Story creator Ryan Murphy
was the story of Elisa Lam. As explored in
the 2021 Netflix documentary Crime Scene:
The Vanishing at the Cecil Hotel, Canadian
student Lam stayed at the Cecil during a trip
to Los Angeles in 2013... only to disappear.
An internet-driven manhunt ensued, especially
after the release of a bizarre surveillance
video of Lam acting erratically in a Cecil
Hotel elevator. A few days later, Lam's body was
discovered in a rooftop water tank. Murphy summed
up the puzzling circumstances at a Television
Critics Association event in August 2015 -
"A girl got in an elevator in a downtown
hotel. She was never seen again."
The sinister-sounding, postmodern opening sequence
for American Horror Story seems tailor-made for
the show, a combination of spooky, forbidding,
and hypnotic musical themes punctuated by jarring
jump-scare sounds. Surprisingly, the bulk of
it comes from a 20-year-old class project.
Back in 1998, César Dávila-Irizarry
was a sophomore at the University of
Puerto Rico. For a music history class, he
created a primitive digital audio track,
using Cool Edit 96 on his Windows
98 computer, stretching, mixing
and combining various sounds with white noise.
For example, the song's first dissonant moment
comes from a clip of Dávila-Irizarry
dropping wire hangers on a tile floor.
When he was done, Dávila-Irizarry
gave it to his friend, Gabriel Diaz,
who went on to work as a video editor
on the first season of American Horror
Story. He used Dávila-Irizarry's track as a
placeholder, but producers liked it so much
they decided to keep it. For technical and
legal reasons, show composer Charlie Clouser
of Nine Inch Nails recreated and spruced
it up with Dávila-Irizarry's blessing.
Apart from a couple of appearances as Church of
Satan cardinal Samantha Crowe in the Apocalypse
season, actor Naomi Grossman left her mark
on the American Horror Story franchise in
the second-season Asylum story. She portrayed
Pepper, a woman who suffers from microcephaly,
which means someone having a smaller than normal
head. She also possesses many other notable
physical traits, such as large ears, jutting
teeth, a mostly shaved pate, and a top-knot.
Grossman is almost unrecognizable as
Pepper, and her physical transformation
into the character for each episode of
Asylum was a long and involved process,
with Grossman telling Entertainment Weekly -
"The entire process takes about
two and a half to three hours,
and that's with two men working the entire time!"
Freckles and veins were drawn on Grossman's skin,
and then came extensive
prosthetics, which included -
"a forehead complete with punched-in eyebrows,
a nose, ears, and even a bumpy
little spine-piece for my back."
Grossman was also outfitted
for a set of false teeth,
which altered the shape of her mouth
and face. Grossman additionally revealed
that she couldn't even use one of her
eyes thanks to a lens she had to wear.
Songs recorded by Fleetwood Mac, as
well as that band's Stevie Nicks,
permeate the soundtracks of multiple American
Horror Story seasons. That's logical,
as Nicks has long been associated with witches,
dark spirits, and other spooky stuff that's
abundant in the Ryan Murphy horror anthology.
Nicks' bewitching presence is felt most
strongly in the third American Horror Story,
subtitled Coven, where Lily Rabe plays a witch who
deeply loves Nicks' music even before she finds
out the singer is an actual, practicing witch,
too. Nicks makes a cameo late in the season,
and it was tough for American Horror
Story producers to make it happen.
Nicks was friendly with AHS creators Ryan
Murphy and Brad Falchuck, having lent a
hand on a Fleetwood Mac tribute episode of
their series Glee. For American Horror Story,
Nicks told the Los Angeles Times that the creators
asked if they could use her music again, and when
they explained that her songs were an integral
aspect for the lonely character Misty Day,
Nicks acquiesced. When Murphy asked her to appear,
she was terrified at first — she had a terrible
time acting in a fourth grade play and had,
quote, "vowed to stay away" from acting forever.
"This shawl has danced across
the stages of the world and now
it's yours. And good luck with the seven wonders."
Each year, the story, setting,
and characters are different,
but the actors remain the same. From the beginning
of the American Horror Story anthology concept,
creator Ryan Murphy has utilized a collective
of performers, with many of them dutifully
returning for each successive season. However,
when it came time to shoot season nine, 1984,
Murphy had to make do without the use
of some of his most venerable actors.
For example, Evan Peters starred in
eight seasons, then left the show,
citing burnout and an aversion to getting
typecast in horror roles. Sarah Paulson
also appeared in each of the first eight tales,
and Jessica Lange bowed out after four seasons,
then had a small, role-reprising cameo in the
eighth season, which tied several different,
disparate American Horror stories together.
It also involved a large number of actors,
which stretched FX's budget, with FX
CEO Jon Landgraf telling TheWrap -
"It was a monster in terms of the
size of the cast, cost of that cast,"
According to Landgraf, Murphy had to quote,
"clean the slate, start over." When
American Horror Story: 1984 debuted,
it boasted a cast composed mostly of new
and latter-day arrivals to the franchise.
After the soft reboot of American Horror
Story was announced, in the form of an
'80s horror movie-influenced season called
1984, a series fan and video editor named
Corey Vega made a preemptive cut of what he
thought the upcoming episodes' opening credit
sequence ought to look like. In short, Vega
thought it should look extremely '80s. He put
together a rapid-fire clip montage that
included shots of aerobics instructors,
neon-colored cars, moonwalking, and neon
graphics. And because it's supposed to be
an American Horror Story clip, lots
of blood and gore permeated it all.
The video spread around the internet until
it reached a very influential figure:
co-creator and producer Ryan Murphy. Murphy wrote
on Instagram that he was such a fan of the edit
that he hired Vega to recreate his video with
AHS titles designer Kyle Cooper to use in 1984.
Lots of people have a fear of clowns, known
as coulrophobia. It must be something about
their frozen, exaggerated, and untrustworthy
grins, or how their identity is concealed under
white face paint. American Horror Story aptly
exploited those fears in its Freak Show season,
featuring John Carroll Lynch as the monstrous
Twisty the Clown, who isn't so much a children's
party entertainer as he is a guy who kills people
with scissors and locks kids in an old school bus.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, this subplot
upset some real-life clowns, as Clowns
of America president Glenn Kohlberger
said in response to Freak Show in 2014 -
"Hollywood makes money sensationalizing
the norm. They can take any situation no
matter how good or pure and turn it
into a nightmare. We do not support
in any way, shape, or form any medium that
sensationalizes or adds to coulrophobia."
The protests flared up again in 2017, when
American Horror Story: Cult, once again,
featured evil clowns. World Clown Association
president Pam Moody told the Detroit Free Press -
"The role of a clown persona,
regardless of their style of clowning,
is meant to bring joy and laughter,
to bring humor to a hurting world."